[Music]
Thanks to you, my second life is fairly faithful.
[Music] That's
why I fell in love with the king, but
one day I felt a tingle in my heart that we were connected.  I'll
buy you naughty underwear,
so
I'm happy. Registration
completed. Let's get
married.
The king has decided to go to the workshop of Babylon. I'll
be the 7th person.
Thank you. What
should we name the country?
Advertisement
[Music]
Run! A
foreign object has entered this world.  I'm trying not to let it happen. There's a crack in the
barrier, and the guy from earlier is slipping through it.
[Music]
Search
Battle
[Applause] It
's a weapon frame gear.
Is this the time of war against Babylon? As the
Phrases progress, the world changes.
Even if it's on the verge of extinction
[Music]